hello my name is dr stephen hoddy um and
i'm going to be
speaking to you today about
combinational approaches to
immunotherapy
and using noam as an example
so as a clinical investigator i look at
the treatment development of immune
therapies
in several ways so it's really the
future of human cancer and how this
evolves into immune therapy intervention
so as opposed to pre-clinical animal
models
tumors and humans are present for a long
period of time and therefore there's a
long
tumor host relationship metastases
likely develop
in relationship to some form of immune
recognition in patients
and so why do patients who develop
metastatic disease
do so despite this immune surveillance
aspect
well either innate immune tumor
responses and patients never developed
there could be problems with the anger
presenting machinery such as mmhc class
1 laws
t-cells can be eliminated they can be
insufficient or exhausted
or the immune effector cells themselves
could be excluded from the tumor
environment and not
gaining access to tumor from the
vasculature
so in the beginning at first the the
first target for
immune therapy from immune checkpoint
blockade was cytotoxic t
lymphocyte antigen 4 or chla4 and the
basic principle here in this cartoon
is that the professional energetic cell
should be a dendritic cell
or b cell it's dropped as to chop up
protein into peptides presented on the
surface the mhc is depicted by
this this red diamond-shaped figure here
and presents it by the mhc to the t-cell
receptor
to educate a naive t-cell to make a
specific immune response against that
peptide
in order for that to occur you have to
have co-stimulation and the epc side is
b7
on the t-cell side of cd28 these come
together to allow the t-cell to gain its
its ability to do its seeking destroy
mission on an andro specific level
it allows the t cells to replicate and
make important
signaling cytokines such as
interleukin-2
now if this would go untethered the
t-cells would go and start
reacting to normal tissues and you would
get autoimmunity and actually the
knockout mouse this huge flavor knockout
mouse is demonstrated um
in a phenotype of an overwhelming
proliferative disease that might cite
for a very young age from this
hormone lymphocyte disease so it shows
the importance of cyclic4
as a checkpoint so in this regulatory
capacity the c34 comes out on the
surface of the t cell
has a higher binding affinity to b7 and
kind of puts us to sleep
thereby making memory cells and other
aspects so
first proof of human principle here we
use fully human molecular antibodies to
block secret4 to allow this
preferential t cell potentiation allow
these t cells to go with their seek and
destroy emission
to kill cancer cells so this was a study
that led to the approval for anticipate4
or epileumab or ippi for short this was
a study done in patients with mistake
melanoma
they could have been previously treated
they had to be previously treated they
had to be hla a2 positive because the
control arm here is a gp 100 peptide
vaccine
and they could have had previously
treated central nervous system disease
so
historically these are bad players
second line patients or more
and ha and particularly patients with
brain metastases
in the three to one one fashion patients
were randomized to hippolyme
hippie anticipate4 plus the peptide
vaccine
versus it be alone versus the peptide
vaccine in a blinded fashion
after four cycles of therapy patients
were followed and any patients who had
stable responding disease continue to be
followed and upon
any signs of progression further on were
again
retreated with the regime that they were
previously randomized to
what this capital my analysis
demonstrates that that patients who
receive the two
containing arms these two top grafts had
an overall improvement in survival
compared to the peptide vaccine alone
some important points here is that
patients
um had a take kind of a tail occur
phenomenon so my
minority receiving majority of the
benefit that the
immune system seems to have memory in
that despite many patients only getting
four doses or
or stopping or intermittent dosing that
they still have the ability to adapt to
changes to the cancer and have a
long-term benefit
again here depicted by this kill the
current phenomenon
now with up to 10 years of follow-up in
patients we'll be mixing our apples and
oranges in terms of the dose and
schedule of aphelion map
we now have about 22 percent of patients
in this tail of the curve with this
inflection point around two and a half
three years
about approximately 22 of patients
having long-term survival
to a single agent if you learn about
patients with menstrual melanoma
but the world has changed very fast and
certainly targeting
the molecule pd-1 has become very
prominent
and just to for this cartoon to define
the biology
on the left-hand side we were looking at
c2a4 in terms of
education of the t-cells and such but
even when the t cells
are educated circulate and make it make
themselves into the tumor
microenvironment
they are still kind of stiff armed by
the tumor they activated tsl the tumor
microbial frequently express
the gaussian marker pd1 and tumors make
the one of the natural ligands pdl one
and this interaction prevents the t
cells from killing the tumor
actually the importance of this molecule
in pre-clinical animal models has
demonstrated
that this interaction actually causes t
cells in
viral models to undergo apoptosis of
program cell death
and while not the only checkpoint in the
tooth that's involved it's certainly a
dominant one as
anti-p1 and ndpdl1 antibodies have
shown a broad efficacy across multiple
tumor types both
solved in the blue tumors so again using
fully human monoclonal antibiotic
technology
antivirus to antipedia one had been
developed for the treatment of melanoma
so this is just kind of the first other
plot there's severe plants showing
the volume out here at three milligrams
per kilogram in previously treated
patients melanoma
and on the y-axis is the change in tumor
volume from the start of treatment zero
being starting treatment
the volume the tumor vitamin c treatment
and on the
axis is the time administration
achievement
you can see the majority of patients
here have responding either either
responses or stabilization
and these red triangles depict new sites
of disease
and by standard criteria these patients
would be deemed
progression for progressive in disease
progression
but even in the presence of new lesions
many patients can have stabilization or
even response disease over time
and again long-term follow-up for
patients um
here depicts that with now five years
function and volume up again in
typically pre-treated patients despite
the dosing schedule that approximately
now third
35 or so patients have have a long-term
survival again in this inflection point
that
occurs sometime around two and a half to
three years
the next question is well if you have
the checkpoint c284 and you have a
checkpoint pd1 what if you combine
antivirus to both of those and so this
is the first combination of the nt64
plus anti-p1 and melanoma
depicted here are the doses and what we
see now the spider plots is
rapid reduction into tumor burden and
durability with many patients having
responses both seen here in the spider
plot and on the early cat scan is an
example of patients within the first few
months
and subsequent to this the phase three
trial whose
um endpoint was to compare neboplastic
to it be and nevo did it be it was not
specifically designed to prepare a
needle to beat nevo
but here now with up to five years of
follow-up patients receive the
combination had a 52 percent
loss follow rate versus patients who
had uh nevo a low of 44 percent and it
be alone 26
the combination does have higher degree
of high grade adverse events as we know
with about 50 percent of patients having
high grade adverse events in the
combination
but these survival curves continue to be
followed in further detailed analysis
so the next question is how can we
improve upon these results how can we
now
look past the great strides here
in two checkpoints for a cancer and look
beyond what other combinational
approaches could be considered in the
advocacy standpoint
so previously we had done studies
looking
at patients receiving anti-seizing iv
who had had
previous treatment with a whole cell gm
csf secreting vaccine and basically what
this pathology shows i think part of
this the importance of pathology of
defining mechanisms in patients
is post-treatment biopsies have shown
this chronic deposit of melanoma
the viable rim of tumor and that viable
room of tumor is heavily infiltrated by
multiple effector immune cells including
c4 style cd8 cells d20 cells
but what we also interestingly found is
that many
of the blood vessels feeding these tumor
deposits had this immune mediated
vasculopathy depicted here this is the
sick blood vessel the lymphocytes
surrounding the endothelium the crack
from being the center
but the vessel itself is the vessel
feeding the tumor
itself is being attacked by the immune
system so this was intriguing
and that the new system could
selectively attack the blood vessels
specific
to tumor deposits potentially so this
raises
one of the questions of the role of
antigenesis and immune regulation and so
um we know hypoxia increases one alpha
that jeff
veget itself can be a very potent
regulator of dendrixel maturation other
cells such as mylateric suppressor cells
macrophages make
uh digest and suppress immune systems so
there's a role for potentially
those molecules in suppression immune
system
so um working with our colleagues in
moral cell encountering
we looked at the potential for
pre-treatment vegf levels in terms of
immunovascopathy i've depicted this and
what we found
is that patients who had high
ventricular levels with
herbicide had a decrease in survival and
improv and responses to patients with
lower vegetable levels
so that in addition to the pathology
that i showed you
the effects of edge of on the immune
system maturation
t cell trafficking in this data and
baseline visual
ventricles decided to look in a clinical
trial
of um if umab
what we found is is response rates
overall about 18 but durable disease
control by 50 percent of patients
at the maximum tolerated doses complete
responses of over 35 percent
with durable stable disease of 50 or
more
and um so fairly impressive compared to
if you live alone
and here's a pet scan
and one patient who showed um before and
after
that the petitivity goes down but the
anatomic
lesion in the liver does not change
significantly
and so it kind of shows that this
patient took time before this lesion
began to shrink and that
the pet scan shows the dynamic aspects
of the immune responses that
my standard ct criteria took a while to
appreciate
so looking at the peripheral blood
before and after comparing to a group of
patients received hippie alone
some of the interesting characters that
fell out is both in the city foreign
department so there were
improvements in memory responses
compared to those patients who've got it
alone
as a function of treatment and even
though small
in retrospective there was some
significant p values by flow psychometry
so it raises the notion of whether
blocking vegeta or targeting vegeta
could have some effects on immune memory
and circling blood
this is an area of pt investigation
so pathologically was important to look
at what's happening before and after
so on the left hand side here um we have
before and on treatment biopsies on ippy
plus
habit and then we have some um similar
biopsies
on ip alone before and after and we
found is that patients receive that with
systomab or anti-vegf
seem to have qualitatively a large
number of cd8 infiltrating cells
even some cc13 cells which could be the
myeloid direct suppressor cells or
dendritic cells that's
further work is involved but we also saw
morphologically that the
cd31 endothelium of the blood vessels
changed they became more plump
columnar they also seem to have violent
biochemical
activation markers such as upper
regulation and eselectin
in surroundings blood vessels was a very
robust lymphocytic infiltrated immune
infiltrate that seemed to be
much more so than patriotic alone so it
suggested potentially whether vegf
blockade could be activating these
endothelium both morphologically and
biochemically
to facilitate lipstick trafficking from
the blood into the tumor
microenvironment
so we also have found that there's
alterations in adhesion molecules such
as vpn and icam on the blood vessels
following
the smith treatment that may be further
hints as to the
changes in endothelium that has led to
um
to the facilitation of lymphocytes
crossing the endothelium
so we
this work has further been developed
and has been kind of confirmed that
vivacismapp can increase
lymphocyte infiltrates potentially even
as a similar agent in
pre-criminal models and in other
clinical applications and uh obviously
the
the cancer to focus on is kidney cancer
and it really looks like the combination
of anti-pd1 pembalizumab plus
exignib which is a tki veteran of r123
inhibitor
seems to have a significant improvement
in progression overall survival
in patients with kidney cancer so this
notion of combining
anti-angiogenesis with immune checkpoint
blockade
seems to be blossoming a bit
particularly in
kidney cancer it needs further
investigation elsewhere
so anti-vegf and others c34 can be
safely administered um maybe blocks
important things that lead to
synergistic effects and this is probably
characterized by inflammatory events
immune activation benefits
in terms of the effects potentially and
then this
i need to look at other engineering
factors may also have imported me ready
for roles
and in potential accommodations for the
future
so we next asked kind of a question of
what drives the response to checkpoint
blockade
and we set up um cytopanels and cytok
panels are
are using um antibodies that are
conjugated to heavy metals and and using
mass
the mass of these these heavy metals to
detect the markers on immune cells as
opposed to flow cytometry
in doing so instead of having a 10 12
colors with low cytometry
you can now do scores of markers with
the same samples and this is just
looking at
a similar panel where we're interested
for psychologists to look at the
peripheral blood of patients
before treatment who received antipedia
one alone or anti-64 alone
to see if there's anything predictive in
terms of the prime immune system other
aspects that could be
predictable outcomes
and there were certainly differences of
lymphocyte and monocyte frequencies that
distinguish responders from
non-responders
to anti-64 and ntpd-1 so we
specifically had found for pembrolizumab
but the number of monocytes in
non-responders
was lower than patients who responded
and as well in
patients with lymphocytes for pimples
that seem to be a little bit
higher responders than in
human responders but importantly when we
look at specific
markers in detail for patients which one
one of the striking features that came
out is that there was decreased
expression of cd69 mip 1b positive and k
cells and baseline pvmcs
to pd1 suggesting that some nka
activation
and proliferative markers might be
involved in the efficacy of ntpd1 um
we know that you can be on nk cells uh
and so this remains another
active air investigation and may be
supportive of
the next study we'll talk about
so what two attacks on two micrograms
contribute immune checkpoint
blockade resistance so
there are a number of areas of
investigation that's looking at that so
as a predictive biomarker the pressure
absence of cd8 infiltrate and the tumor
right arrive particularly at the tumor
strong interface
the c8 cells present there have been
predictive of
a beneficial response to pd-1
um the presence of interference
signatures infrastructure
argument is also very beneficial but
things that have been associated with
potential resistance to atp one have
been
mutations in tumors and cells
particularly like jack mutations which
will not permit
interferon signaling um p1 expression
has been a circuit for interferon to
some extent
it's a useful ligand and aspects of the
apc machinery specifically beta2
mutations which
would not allow class 1 to be expressed
in the tumor and therefore cd cells
would
be challenging to to lyse them and kill
those cells so those are kind of the
thoughts about what the next steps of
investigation would include
so we were interested in looking at the
whether class one loss could be
mechanism resistance
and also not just class one blood small
potential class two expression
relative checkpoint blockade which has
been an area investigation by a number
of groups
so we took advantage of this um
this investigation study of
a randomized study where patients with
mestachmonomers front line
but they were randomized to either
receive induction the volume out of
enterprise first with a forced switch
to ipilumab and t64 and the other half
of patients were
received ambulance first for the force
switched to nebo
in between everyone got blood work but
they've got a 5c before
biopsy in between the two induction
periods of icy following
and then everyone received the volume
maintenance
and um in this
study we looked at by protein and iec
uh scott wrote it doing much of this
work uh in reading this work
class one expression here and here's
examples of high plasma expression
most nucleated normal cells will have uh
intact plasma expression
intermediate cosmic expression the tumor
cells here that have lost classical
expression
there are some patients with class 2
expression here
most cells will not have classical
expression as opposed
in the medium to loss of a lack of
positive expression
so we looked at the patients who got
ippy first versus patient needle first
what we found is that patients who had a
down regulation of class 1
that is a 50 reduction or loss of class
1
um um did not
have his favorable outcomes to if the
illuminati
therapy first and that they were really
the benefits
any benefits were dependent on class 1
expression being
fairly normal this was not true for
class 2 expression
what we found in evil first this was
that the classroom was not
influential whether patients had a
clinical benefit or not
but that any expression of class ii that
being even one percent
that's scored by two independent
pathologists even any expression of
class two
associated with a favorable outcome to
antiphone therapy
and here are some capital minor analysis
that kind of depicts this the greater a
few patients who were not
valuable but the patient had ippy first
who had
loss of class 1 expression in red did
fairly
poorly compared to those in the blue
that um on the left-hand side that
um that had class one intact and as
opposed to those patients needle first
the right um that there was no specific
difference between
um as opposed to class two but on the
left hand side
first not seem to matter but there was a
significance in the right-hand side for
page grand nebo first that any classical
expression was associated with a better
outcome
so we next looked at the top genes are
associated with this
and this is listing many of the genes
that we found because all the patients
had rna sequence some sequencing
and what we found was that
patients here most of these
uh associations top genes were
associated with gamma interference
signaling
that you would expect and interestingly
some were
associated with not only only
but also other potential microbes such
as il-15
which is involved with nk biology
so we looked at the genes for those
patients who had
low class 1 expression and in patients
who got an ego first
the presence of interference symmetry
the published signature the top five
genes we looked at in our own
interference signature
portfolio um gene signature that
patients who had this interferon
signature infrared signaling
did better to nevo first those that do
not and the interestingly in comparison
those pictures got it be first
those signatures did not seem to
influence outcomes of the idp first
we took the patients who had low class
one expression began
to see well what else is going on in the
two member environment and it seems that
you need interferon to still respond to
antipede one
signature but other genes that were
associated with it
included uh uh cells
of innate immunity here gamma delta
cells on the left
on the top and then in case and k cells
on the on the bottom here
and when we looked it was seemed to be
significant for those who got
nevo first as opposed to those guys
first
and we're able to look at pathology
scott and his colleagues were able to
erode against colleagues we will find
these um gamma delta cells and nk cells
in the tumor micro environment
so we next look to um the this trial to
see if we can confirm this in this trial
was used as a registration trial for
needle pacified melanoma
and randomized patients in a two-to-one
fashion to amigo plus it be
aluminum placebo and so we were able to
take samples from from this
and score them to look at the
and confirm the characteristics to see
if both class one
and class two could be involved and what
we
found in the ip alone containing arm
is that down regulation or loss of class
1 had 100 negative predictive value
for outcome meaning that anyone who did
did fairly poorly
and while there were trends and what we
saw earlier for me would be given it's a
combination
um there was nothing that was it was
significant but there was a
confirmation of the importance of class
one to
um to the benefits of receiving a
dealing math
so here are the kappa m iron outs again
it's encoded for ippy
on on the left for class one expression
patients who had lower loss of class one
did not do as well as patients who had
intact class one
and because this combination that the
nivo hippie arm did not see
such a significance but again while
there was a
trend towards the importance of class
two in the needle containing arm
it's not really smooth against obviously
patients getting both in group
mississippi
so in summary um if there's a
appearance that sees for blockade
responses is depend on class one and
that
p one blockade is not entirely dependent
on class one but interestingly
p m blocky responses can be improved by
class 2 expression any class 2
expression by the presence of gamma
interferon
so much of this intriguing information
is is asking to be looked at in other
cancers and such but also suggests that
the potential
that that a gamma interferon signature
may be from
class 2 expressions cd4 help with making
gamma
can activate multiple effector cells uh
even
anatomy cells and maybe even the roles
of other cells such as gamma delta cell
gaming the cells as well as nk cells
um in the tumor microbiome it may become
important even
to anticipate or blockade
and so we're working on looking at
multiplex immunofluorescence
of here looking at ways to look at class
1 class 2 beta 2
tumors in order to understand the role
of the abc machinery
class 1 class 2 the other cells in the
micro environment
that are related to the efficacy for
checkpoint blockade
so there's still much work that needs to
be done
specifically here looking at the targets
that are
are still being investigated and uh
in both from a checkpoint standpoint pd1
is obviously up there
and even agonist targets such as uh
cd40 aux 484 and bb so there are many
complexities to the
the tumor engine presenting cell or
tumor t
cell interface that are currently under
investigation
but also of importance is
[Music]
the relevance of these other cells into
microvirumet the cd8 cell is obviously
critical other cells of microbiome that
play a role both in effector
function as well as regulatory function
um um
the drake sulfur engine and one
presentation two macrophages in the
immunity in terms of effector versus
regulatory elements
um t regulatory cells too much a5 blast
these
all play a critical role in the tumor
micro environment
with relation to our ability to develop
further control approaches to treatments
so there have been a number of folks
that have been involved in this work and
a lot of investigation trials i want to
really highlight the importance of the
the teamwork
in in this to be able to conduct these
um early pilot studies to kind of
dissect out some of the negatives in
people